here are 10 things that you didn't know about Spain.
there's about 600 people in a small town
with the last name Yaapawan,
who are all descendants of a 17th century samurai.
Spain is the only European country to
share a land border with Africa
and there are 2 expos of Spain near Morocco.
Spain has autonomous communities,
some that even speak different languages
like Basque and Catalan.
they have 47 UNESCO World Heritage Sites,
the 3rd highest in the world.
the red in the flag represents strength,
yellow generosity and the
symbol pays homage to the original kingdoms of Spain.
they are the
second most visited country by tourists in the world.
Spain is ranked
second in terms of life expectancy in Europe
at 83.22 years.
they produce about 47% of the world's olive oil.
the Sagrada Familia is still technically not finished
after a hundred 40 years of construction.
Spain currently
has the highest unemployment rate in the EU at 12.5.